not to show these boys how you do it you
ready
higher for the foster baby yes
faster
try to keep up
[Music]
Trane's heading for a tunnel up ahead
let's treat them at the station
shapeshifters
[Music]
okay prove the enough scroll
that's a photon blast and I was girl can
I'll do that I'm just supposed to take
your word today
we are Cree strong United
remember control
I have this power
but I don't know where it came from
I've never seen anything like the
beginning hey everybody it's Charlie we
got a bunch of Captain Marvel Super Bowl
trailer footage to break down and I know
there are a lot of questions about
Captain Marvel in the Avengers end game
Super Bowl trailer because so much of it
looks like it's been digitally altered
so that you have no idea what's going on
at some of these scenes so we got to
break it down we're still doing an
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Avengers moment on the video I
named a new winner at the end of this so
if it wasn't clear Captain Marvel is a
big part of Avengers and game that was
what Nick Fury's page was at the end of
infinity war that post-credits scene so
that will connect with the end of
Captain Marvel probably a post-credits
scene that connects to avengers endgame
where she gets that page but we'll talk
about the new Captain Marvel footage
then I'll talk about Captain Marvel
potentially in that Avengers end game
footage like where is she and where did
they just you know pull her out in
Photoshop so that people don't know when
she actually does show up during the
movie the Captain Marvel Super Bowl
trailer footage starts out with Maria
Rambo and Captain Marvel just doing
their little chant to each other a
little or mantra as they're walking out
to get ready to fly planes for flight
exercises or whatever potential mission
they might be on in this particular
sequence the higher further faster
mantra is also of reference to the comic
book story that they're adapting the
Kelly sued iconic Road that's the basis
for a lot of the plot during this
Captain Marvel movie the ship that she's
flying later in the movie when she
actually gets into her accident the
version of the psyche magnetron accident
that activates her powers that's
actually a test ship because they
explained that during the film
she's an Air Force pilot but she's also
a test pilot so she flies a lot of
experimental aircraft so we'll talk
about that in a second because I think
this has a lot to do with the government
and shield experimenting quote-unquote
with alternate energy sources like you
hear Nick Fury talking about when they
finally got the tesseract we had a long
conversation about how the mine stone
unlocked scarlet witch's latent
abilities so she's sort of like a proto
mutant for the MCU even though they
don't technically call it that
like the mines don't unlock stuff that
was already there they've already
explained that they've changed Captain
Marvel's origin story a little bit for
the movie the cool thing that they've
implied is a similar situation with
unlocking her abilities brie Larson
explained that the accident enhances her
it doesn't give her powers technically
so like she already has
potential for power or like the MCU
current version of the x-gene whatever
you want to call it they're gonna get
the x-men characters pretty soon so
it'll be a non-issue by the end of the
year but she already has this latent
ability the accident enhances that and
she's flying a u.s. test aircraft so
very clearly they've been experimenting
with some kind of energy we don't know
if this is some sort of soft reboot or
retcon of their pre-existing backstory
or if this is infinity stone energy but
it's just meant to invoke a lot of
references to Scarlet Witch getting her
powers unlocked by the mine stone which
obviously infinity stone so which is
another unifying theory for unlocking
people's powers the quantum realm is
just like the newest addition to that so
that could also have something to do
with this too because they've just
started to explain that in the MCU
whatever the energy source is it has
something to do with this us test
aircraft that she's getting in when
she's flying from what looks like either
a Kree or a scroll ship they both go
down it's implied that then the scroll
comes for her she tries to take it down
or it gets blown up Jude Law's on ragna
PSA's the whole thing senses what a
powerful asset she would be in their war
against the Skrulls seized the skills
that she already has before she got
powers and hatches his plan to take her
broken body back to the annette bening
supreme intelligence who puts her
through the reconditioning program that
wipes her memories enhances her
physiology even more and makes her seem
like more of a pink skin cream by a'
logically so early theory about annette
bening she winds up being the supreme
intelligence and the actual villain of
the film now there are a lot of bad
people during the film like Jude Law is
very clearly lying to her about her
backstory so he's kind of an antagonist
Talos and the Skrulls are also very evil
so they're technically antagonists too
but when you have two terrible groups of
people like the scrolls in the Kree and
it's a comic book film a Marvel film you
still need to have at least one person
that you can point to and say this is
definitely the worst person in the film
punch them in the face kill them blow
them up in some cathartic moment because
whatever they may have done it's
supposed to be way worse than what the
other bad people in the movie or the
scrolls have been doing so if she's
playing the supreme intelligence it all
makes sense because if you're not a big
comic book reader the supreme
intelligence is an entity whose sole
purpose is the evolution and supremacy
of the Kree it has no sense of morality
only a psychopathic drive to achieve its
goals and it will use whatever it needs
to justify that if you're Steven
universe fan or if you've ever watched
that show she would be like the white
diamond of the movie someone who smiles
but it's like the emotionless smile you
get from a serial killer who's just
faking it trying to pretend like it has
emotions it's all lie to get you to do
what she wants you to do so early theory
it's Annette Bening controlling
everything and everyone using them to
win the kree-skrull war manipulating
them by just telling them whatever she
thinks they need to hear at the
beginning of the trailer Maria Rambo
says you ready for this and she says
higher further faster sort of her mantra
Maria Rambo replies let's fade that's
also probably what Maria Rambo tells
Captain Marvel later in the film to
remind her of her past just reciting the
catchphrase to her whenever she comes
back and it becomes this big rallying
cry for her late in the film whereas
earlier in the film it's just something
that she started saying to herself to
get pumped up before a big flight
there's a much better shot of them
charging their weapons in this Star
Force mission early in the film it seems
like they're just going after some
Scrolls and it looks like yon rock also
has some energy base photon powers think
he's got a gun in one hand and his other
arm is charging with what looks like
similar photonic powers to Captain
Marvel but not quite the same thing that
would actually make a lot more sense for
their potential fight at the end of the
film and this frame here like it looks
like he's wearing a slightly different
gray uniform and they get ready to fight
each other if he were to have similar
powers to her it would be a little more
balanced in their final fight it would
make more sense for their arc across the
film because all this other trailer
footage makes it seem like he's trying
to actually mentor her through the Kree
military where you see the two of them
he keeps telling her that she's not
quite ready she needs to watch out he
takes her down pretty easily during what
looks like a sparring match early in the
film so he's kind of like Vegeta shading
her across the film just telling her
you're not quite good enough at this
point you're not quite as powerful as me
in the whole idea of the film is that in
rediscovering her past she also realizes
her full potential for power in a
suddenly like oh I could fly this whole
time I could go binary this whole time I
just didn't believe in myself enough so
it's like marina Rambo her friend here
and Nick Fury helped her realize that
because we got that clip a little while
ago with Maria Rambo at Monica Rambo's
house where it looks like she makes her
comic book costume or repurposes her
green creased star force
uniform into the comic-book uniform the
last couple of scenes of her going
binary and blowing all these ships up
are a little out of order first it looks
like she and a fury take off in that
prototype Quinn jet looking ship he
screams and excitement fist bumping her
then she goes binary jumps out of the
back of the ship when they're at high
altitude hooks out on this other ship
chasing them by literally punching the
spaceship out of the sky Hulk's smash
style like I'm sure Hulk will have a lot
of fun with Captain Marvel then
continues on into outer space blowing up
the ships around the planet with her
binary powers the other cool thing about
this ship two people have asked about
the Nova Corps in this movie I don't
know that this is necessarily Nova Corps
but the ship design looks very similar
to the Milano ship design so even if it
doesn't come from the exact same place I
think they're trying to be consistent in
the ship design that comes from that
area of space because the Nova Corps the
Kree in the scrolls are all from around
the same quadrant of the galaxy but
talking about Captain Marvel in the
Avengers end game Super Bowl trailer so
remember like a lot of this could be
digitally altered so they're couple
scenes where it looks like characters
have either been taken out wholesale
words meant to be very misleading you
have all the Avengers walking out to the
fields here in the middle of the night
looking up at the sky and something is
coming down clearly from the other side
of the frame that could be when Captain
Marvel arrives because it seems like
it's relatively early in the film Black
Widow still has relatively short blonde
hair so not as much time as passed since
the end of infinity warp you also don't
see ant-man in anywhere this footage
here so unless they taken him out it
also implies this relatively early in
the course of the film so I don't know
the Captain Marvel would show up before
ant-man because it seems like they're
trying to introduce the idea of him
showing up then talking about all this
quantum realms stuff trying to hatch a
plan then her showing up later is like a
whole big separate thing because it's
such a monumental event like Captain
Marvel becoming part of the Avengers
that they're probably gonna give her a
Thor Wakanda level introduction during
the film like they want to hype her up
so Thor arriving in Wakanda is probably
one of the best moments from that film I
wouldn't be surprised if they gave
Captain Marvel a similar style
introduction so this obviously doesn't
seem too spectacular so it could be Tony
and nebula arriving could be Captain
Marvel but other important thing to
remember too is the Kevin Feige
confirmed that most of the trailer
footage we've been saying is from
relatively early in the film like first
thirty minutes of the film and I think
the Captain Marvel will probably show up
after that first 15 minutes like even
though there might be some references it
won't be the very beginning of the film
because the beginning is gonna be them
dealing with the grief like all this
footage that we see in the Superbowl
trailer with them trying to figure out
what to do next like where do we go next
now that everybody's gone how do we deal
with this grief so let me know in the
comments when do you think the Captain
Marvel shows up during Avengers endgame
I've got a couple other Marvel videos
that I'm working on I'll try to get out
as fast as possible
congratulations CK band you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to re-watch that Avengers end
game trailer a billion more times and
click here for all that other Captain
Marvel footage that drop this weekend
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]